hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to neverending
nightmares we're still among the
horrible copies of me I'm imagining that
all the dead bodies from the last Asylum
part that got piled up were transformed
into a more beautiful version to myself
it's a must
bigger smile and stronger abdominals and
also a giant axe to stab me in the back
ah my back hurts I've been stabbed too
many times I know what's gonna happen
but I'm gonna tough through it I don't
feel pretty good for ah oh never mind I
don't oh sorry I just need to imbibe
some water ah damn good stuff okay carry
on
sorry about that still just a little bit
left over from my cold very my double
ear infection whatever you want okay
nevermind that was a wrong click sorry
sorry sorry sorry sorry i intruded
that's my bad I am rude carry on there
friend
so I'm as in there blocking off
different sections of this place that I
will go to later when I drop in a hole
and I'm able to access a different area
the same asylum that has something else
actually this isn't an asylum this is a
hospital this one in particular is
hospital oh hi
we're right then okay why what was the
point why do I just need to peer into
something and know my own death so I'm
gonna stab me what's behind this curtain
and nothing come on y'all can have
anything behind the curtain nothing no
Easter egg no special surprise secret
damn damn damn damn
someone here huh someone gonna run stab
me from behind provide Wow remind I know
I know I know I know I knew it
go go go go go set the son of a [ __ ]
autopsy B oh is autopsy B Oh autopsy B
is without a body
well let me volunteer myself no thank
you hmm
I know lucky shut up what happens if
like now I don't want to go back I'm
curious but not that curious hello is
there any reason for me to be here no
okay bye
I don't get why there's so many just
nondescript empty rooms rooms not rooms
apparently anything anything with a run
stabbed agenda what is that on the
ground what is that um oh it's nothing
okay I could have sworn I saw eyes on
the ground there hang on let me zoom in
on that are you guys seeing what I'm
seeing with the eyes there Nana my
nevermind
I'm just being dumb just being paranoid
and dumb for good reason yeah honey sons
of [ __ ] they're everywhere
well I did die alot so that would
explain a lot unless it's just like the
same guy naw naw it's not the same guy
the doors banging from over there
ho ho
is there another really sad cremation
happening over there I mean oh go to
another hole that's what she he said I
don't know oh go ahead pause wondering
when I was gonna get my dick candle
again here we go oh my favorite oh this
is my favorite oh I love everything
about this oh good okay okay
as if it couldn't get any better as if I
couldn't possibly get any better now
never know if something's gonna murder
stab me I know I know
oh I knew I knew I knew right away I
knew right away know
no murder stabbed no murder no murder
okay hope I'm going the route oh god
this is a crying lady there's very sad
pelvic exam happening in the other room
hello who's crying
can I help you Missy Gabi is that you
Kabri Ella all right ba ba you have a
good time I'll be off so someone's
crying in a hospital is what I'm
guessing I'm in a coma that would be the
typical horror thing that goes on when
you're having a never-ending nightmare
and you have to wake up from it
okay no murder again I like this I like
this dead ends no murderer
I'll take boring over that thing coming
after me I didn't even see it this time
might not have been the same guy might
have been really friendly dude probably
not though I know the odds are always in
my favor
I ran too early I'm gonna run out of
juice oh oh I thought I was dead for
sure
oh good oh that's why my back hurts
until tense it's getting giving me the
heebie-jeebies
also I can hear everything volume still
really loud in my ears
I got a table flip sure whoa wait whoa
oh yeah well let me just pelvic thrust a
little bit to warm up yeah well IRL whoa
we will we will hey whoo hee whoo
we will we will we were only whoa I
don't know why I filled in the Oh wake
up what Thomas please wake up
Oh God believe
Thomas you're awake oh my god you're
just gonna end it like that oh god why
happened so suddenly did I miss some
what hasn't it be you're gonna do that
white boy oh my goodness
that ended so suddenly and so sadly I
thought he was just in a coma barely
using the in the in the hospital Micah's
he attempted suicide to slit his wrists
I get that explains by the with the
pulling out of the thing in the bone
maybe that's what he actually did I have
no idea in real life I have no idea oh
man it harkens back to uh the mask
reveals disgusting face at the end of it
it was about a person's personal
experience fighting depression and like
fighting the monster inside themselves
now
that was really interesting because it
gave this kind of insight into it that a
lot of people don't understand if
they've never been through depression
but I must say the same thing that I
said there and i'ma say that when I
first played this I can I was speaking
with a developer before I played and he
tell me that this is like an adventure I
into his own battles with depression and
mental illness so I said in the other
video that if you are going through
mental illness or you suffer through
depression I mean it's a real issue
people need to understand that it is
it's real even if it's not real to you
because you've never experienced
depression or you just think they all
they are going through a rough time
it's real to them it's like the most
real thing in their entire life so if
you're going through this problems or
depression or anything there was a
website that flew by but there's a lot
of resources and just I want to save it
you know this community really rallied
around the net last time I
talk about this I really want you guys
to know that I saw some beautiful things
happening on tumblr there were people
reaching out and just reaching out to
people who have been through tough times
and are really going and through a low
point in their life and I want you to
know that this community can help you
like maybe not in the youtube comment
sections like my youtube comment
sections are usually pretty good but if
you go to like the individual
communities on Tumblr Facebook there's
Twitter stuff going on all the time but
there's always support out there for you
guys so I want you guys to know that
you're not alone I in any of this so if
you're suffering through depression or
something like that or you think in a
self-harm then definitely know oh there
were branching paths i annoy idea Oh
what could I have done differently
I don't know I don't know what I could
have done it was a linear path up to
there all I don't know if I have time or
the patience to go through everything to
try to do a different thing again but I
don't know what it does I don't know how
it do I don't know what I experience
different from other people so that
means that the other lens flares that
have been doing this I know there's been
a bunch that have been playing this game
but there are other ways you can go
through this game I may not play myself
but check around there's bound to be
other playthroughs that you can enjoy to
find the endings for this I'm sure
there's a video that just summarizes all
the endings alone so either way thank
you all so much for watching thank you
for joining me on this great adventure
and remember what I said if you're going
through a tough time
there's always going to be help out
there for you and just know that there
are other alternatives there's any other
alternatives besides hurting yourself so
just reach out and if you're in a good
situation your life and you see someone
suffering be that person who reaches out
to them first because sometimes they're
you know they're going through
they're afraid so you know take some
time to reach out and try to help
someone in the world today so anyway
just thank you all so much for watching
check out my other playthroughs in the
description below or over in the
annotation there I've done tons of cool
horror games like this that really
explore a lot of emotional topic so it's
amazing a horror just touches on
visceral stuff that not a lot of other
games get to I mean it may seem like a
grotesque a horror Rocky Horror Picture
Show type thing that's just kinda
showcasing it just to showcase it but
there's meaning to it there's always
going to be meaning to thank you all so
much for watching and as always I'll see
you in the next one
Oh dick with me is your doing